I can this episode is brought to you by
ship station if you've ever sold
anything online or if you sell anything
online then you know what a pain in the
ass the shipping process is it's
time-consuming it's expensive
you're always copying and pasting orders
from different sites trying to figure
out the best carrier so on and so forth
it's such a hassle and in a previous
life I shipped tens of thousands of
units overseas domestically overnight
ground every possible carrier it drove
me bonkers ship station was created to
make your life easier I wish I had had
it when I was in the biz so to speak it
has the most five-star reviews of any
shipping software four point nine out of
five for Magento users four point eight
out of five for Shopify users four point
five out of five for big commerce users
it goes on and on whether you're selling
on eBay Amazon Shopify or more than 100
other popular selling channels
shipstation lets you access all of your
orders from one simple dashboard ship
station works with all of the major
shipping carriers locally and globally
including FedEx UPS and the major local
couriers like USPS ship station will
recommend the best carrier for your
needs so that you know that you're
always getting the best deal they even
offer discounts on shipping costs that
are available to say you as a one-person
shop that would normally be thought of
as reserved for large fortune 500
companies so there are a lot of benefits
no other shipping platform makes
shipping faster easier and more
affordable and right now Tim Ferriss
show listeners get to try ship station
free for 60 days when you use promo code
Tim it's risk free you can start your
free trial without even entering your
credit card info just visit ship station
com click on the microphone at the
the homepage and type in tim t IM that
shipstation comm enter promo code Tim
check it out shipstation calm promo code
Tim this episode is brought to you by
ring this season can be a whirlwind of
deliveries visitors in holiday travel so
it's the best time of the year to
upgrade your doorbell and keep an eye on
home no matter where the holidays take
you I'm traveling a ton and this is key
for me ring helps you stay connected to
your home from anywhere so if there's a
package delivery or a surprise visitor
you'll get an alert and be able to see
hear and speak to them all from your
phone if you're on the go the season
whether it's across town or across the
country you can check in anytime for
some much-needed holiday peace of mind
I've personally used ring for years now
it catches in records all the regular
stuff like deliveries and so on but it's
also saved my ass a few times catching
weirdos and weird things ring is key to
my peace of mind
and as a listener of the Tim Ferriss
show that's you you have a special
holiday offer on a ring welcome kit
available right now with a ring video
doorbell - and chime Pro the ring
welcome kit has everything you need to
keep an eye on home no matter what this
holiday season brings with ring you're
always home just go to ring calm
forward-slash Tim that's ring.com
forward slash Tim check it out
additional terms may apply and this
offer is for us residents only
that is ring.com forward slash Tim
well hello boys and girls ladies and
germs monks and monkfish welcome to
another episode of the Tim Farriss show
this is your host think I've ever said
that before Tim Ferriss and it's my job
every episode to attempt do my best to
deconstruct world-class performers from
different fields of all different types
to find out what their routines are what
their self-talk is like what types of
tools they use and so on and so forth my
guest today is Gary Keller this is a
name that's come up a lot in the last
few years in my friend circles and
particularly since moving to Austin Gary
is the co-founder chairman and CEO of
Keller Williams also known as kW the
world's largest real estate franchise by
agent count in 2019 kW which also ranks
number one in units and sales volume in
the US was named by Fast Company the
most innovative company in real estate
in 2015
Keller began driving Kate abuse
evolution into a technology company now
focused on building the real estate
platform that agents buyers and sellers
prefer he is competing you may note
head-to-head with multi billion-dollar
venture backed companies the difference
among many so I should say one of many
differences is that he's using his own
money which I just love Keller is also
the best-selling author of the one thing
subtitled the surprisingly simple truth
behind extraordinary results we talk
about this quite a bit in our
conversation the millionaire real estate
agent the millionaire real estate
investor and shift you can find him on
Facebook at Gary Keller and you can also
find his new podcast which is called
think like a CEO on all of your podcast
platforms think like a CEO which he
hosts with Jay papasan is described
thusly on Apple podcasts think like a
CEO weaves a narrative of the business
and life lessons including developing
business strategies hiring the right
people and developing a culture that
truly puts people first you can find it
as I mentioned on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you typically find your
podcast now without further ado please
enjoy my wide-ranging conversation with
Gary Keller Gary welcome to the show
thank you Tim happy to be here I have
heard your name dozens hundreds maybe of
times since moving to Austin and
certainly heard the name many times
before that and that that relates to
much of your work in the written word
and I think we'll get to that but I
wanted to start with something I came
across in doing research for this
conversation and feel free to fact-check
because you don't want to believe
everything you read on the Internet of
course but I want to talk about your
childhood a little bit and maybe your
later childhood so it seems like it was
the summer before your junior year that
your dad had you shadow appointments
with a banker an attorney and a realtor
and then a lawyer and a lawyer lawyer
yeah no you said right accountant and a
lawyer and a banker and a realtor got
reformed for him yeah and said like talk
about that if you if you took anything
in particular away from that and also a
quote from your dad which was or in
effect what he passed on to you II he's
he said that anyone he knew who had any
money either made it in real estate or
put it in real estate so could you talk
about that period of time and what he's
what impact that had on you yeah you
know it's interesting I thought I was
actually in high school I thought I was
going to be a rock musician and I gave
no thought to college whatsoever
and the summer after I graduated from
high school I came home one night after
our band had performed and my mother and
dad who were both educators were waiting
up for me a little spooky ride to turn
lights on and they were my parents in
the dark sitting there at the den but I
just plopped down on the couch Tim and I
and I and I said you know I don't think
it's gonna work out I I'm not that good
and I'm not motivated to practice enough
to overcome that I'm not any good and my
and my parents just looked at I mean I
think they knew that by the way
and both being educators my dad said
well we actually applied to a college
and you were accepted if you'd like to
go and that's it really where and they
said Baylor University I went cool I'd
been there once because that an older
sister who had just started going there
and so that was kind of yet tonight my
that's how that's how I got to college
and at the end of my sophomore year
beginning of my junior year that summer
my dad I
he said you probably should get a major
and I went okay I hadn't given any
thought and I loved and I loved to tell
a story to the kids when I teach because
I said maybe you can relate to the fact
that I was clueless about everything and
so dad said well when I set you up to
spend some time with some guys so it was
an accountant a banker or a lawyer and a
realtor and the I liked the realtor Tim
and I liked it I liked it because it was
entrepreneurial is very people-oriented
he didn't have a tie on he didn't he
wasn't in a stuffy corporate feeling
environment right all those all those
sound reasons why you should choose a
profession right but anyway that
appealed to me got back to college
thinking you know real estate what that
guy did was something that was very
appealing to me and Baylor University
had just announced they were launching
that semester of my junior year first
semester a real estate degree program
and it was in real estate and insurance
so that's kind of so I tried up and you
know the rest kind of history so I got
my degree in in real estate and came out
interviewed on a couple of places and
landed in Austin let's let's talk about
and this is maybe one of those places
New York life for a second because I
would assume and again this is a
dangerous business assuming things but
that you are a spectacular ly good at
selling or at least persuading conveying
ideas and my understanding is that
you're put through some type of
assessment could you
yeah what happened yeah that was my that
was an in college and my senior year my
degree plan was in the marketing
department and it was real estate and
insurance so you know the college they
don't they don't teach you much of
anything about leaving the the College
other than teaching you how to interview
so one of the guys that came on campus
was with New York Life and I didn't
realize a turd
discovered that that guy I thought it
was interviewing with New York Life the
corporation but I actually was
interviewing with the the top New York
Life sales person in the area and SUNY
so I went to an interview and they gave
me a behavioral profile assessment and I
got a what felt like a form letter a
couple of weeks later this said I didn't
match the profile of their successful
salespeople and so I would not be made
an offer to join them and the funny
thing is I was so mad about that that I
chose real estate I was furious I mean
you know I have a degree right I have a
degree in real estate insurance I go to
interview for my job and they tell me
I'm not I don't have the the job match
requirements it's almost like you got a
degree in law or whatever and then when
you got out the law firms all told you
you're really not a good match to be a
lawyer it was kind of a it was kind of a
you know freaked me out a little bit
right but I I tended to to respond
pretty strong than that kind of stuff so
I got really mad and I just interviewed
real estate companies and when did you
strike out on your own how did that how
was that capitalized well that was in 83
so when I got out of when I got at
college and interviewed interview two
firms I chose the one in Austin Texas
and had been here I think maybe once or
twice before with my family but I drove
here and interviewed with the firm liked
them agreed to go to work there and
start literally you know launched
launched my my career if you will
through I guess that would be after the
end of the site yeah they'd be in this
summer yeah
did that and by the I sold I sold six
houses my first 30 days in a city that
had only been in a couple of times
before because I'm I kind of believe in
business by the book a little bit you
know my my one of the things that I
don't know where this came from Tim but
I had a well I had a professor make a
profound statement once and he said mr.
Keller II says people have lived before
you you you might want to study what
they know before you go out and start
doing your thing and that that that
makes a lot of sense to me
right so I studied hat while I was still
in college I was reading the books and
studying how to be a successful realtor
so when I hit the ground in us in a city
that I knew you know maybe two people in
I just did everything by the book sold
six houses closed five of them got my
picture in the paper woohoo
when I inside the book in that case
meaning meaning that that I went to I
went to the books I went to the books of
the best real estate trainers at that
time I see this then I buy the book
meaning following the playbook of the
people at the time who were well
respected it exactly that's exactly what
I did
so I outlined all of that created a plan
for myself and then just executed on the
plan and things went well the the funny
thing is is at the end of my I guess it
was the end of the 11th month of my
first full year calendar year my manager
came in and said you're gonna be the
Rookie of the Year you know you're
you're you're 22 years old
yeah I'm not 23 this is amazing it's
awesome and I went numb I'm out of here
again she goes what do you mean I'm
saying well I hit all my goals I made
the amount of money that I wanted to
make bought a condo got a dog got a new
car I got some sir when they get tower
speakers they were like four feet tall
and you know and so I'm done I'm gonna
go take a month off so I I left anyway
came back and I discovered that I was
really kind of a closet trainer meaning
that I was over there helping people and
I've been in the business a year and a
half I'm helping people
and I think I just came by that
naturally temp so long story short I
ended up applying for a management
position in the largest firm in the city
at the time and the owner said I am NOT
going to hire you quite uh let's once
again I'm getting rejected right
he said no one liked me and and you know
I the truth is is is that's probably
correct but but here's what I said doing
and I remember it as clear as day I said
I understand that but I come into the
office and the receptionist is doing her
nails and I have I have clients coming
in and silly me I thought the
environment was supposed to you know
support my goals so I asked her to put
it away and she gets mad at me and then
I go around the corner and their agents
and they've got all their smelly food
out and it's a mess and it's right by
the reception area and I asked him to
clean it up or you know put it away or
something because silly me I thought the
environment was supposed to support me
and they don't like me doing that but I
said if you hire me they'll like me and
we'll all make more money and he said
I'm not hiring you and I don't know
weird and I don't know where this came
from you know it's you know but
somewhere deep inside that was offensive
to me and so I said we'll give me a test
if I pass it you have to hire me and I I
don't think everyone ever talked to this
multi-millionaire you know businessman
and so he actually got a sheet of paper
out he wrote down the things that I need
to accomplish handed it to me and said
go do it
and I had no training in what he'd ask
me to do and and I had no support right
I wasn't getting paid for it
I was just entrepreneurially gonna go
out and achieve this list to get a job
well I think he blew me off and forgot
about it I don't know what buy some of
the things on the list well it was
things like go recruit people to the
firm right but here I am a salesperson
with no training in that right and then
the other one was teach and we'll see
what your ratings will be like it was
just a series of hurdles that I was I
was told to go do and I did my first
recruit was actually out of a book store
I was in the B Dalton bookstore
and I saw a woman looking at the real
estate section and I went over and said
can I help you and and she goes no and
and I was taken back right I said I'm so
sorry and I walked away and a little
while later she came over to me and she
said hey you know I I won't apologize I
I thought you were trying to pick me up
or something and I said well because I'm
a smart aleck tenem I said well the
thought crossed my mind but I said no I
said actually have a degree in real
estate I sell real estate and I love
learning and I've literally read or
browsed almost every book on these
shelves regarding real estate so I
thought I could just help you and she
said well I'm thinking about getting
into real estate and so that was one of
the things on my list I had to go
accomplish right so check that off the
box and I it's really cool when we later
started our firm she was one of the
first 20 agents to come join us but so
that was it said that what what
essentially I didn't did that for about
a year and a half to two years was it
was easily two years now I think about
it
and they they the company did something
that I didn't like and I went in to
resign because the owner had promised me
when he hired me he sent me to the goat
pastures outside of Austin they call it
Round Rock now but it was go pasture and
he didn't give me where all the growth
was going because he'd already hired a
manager for that he said well turns out
that the he hired three managers and
none of them could ever launch that
office and he just had to eat the lease
for three years before he could get out
of it
me on the other hand went up to Round
Rock Georgetown and built a business
that's still there today hugely
successful but he didn't he then did
something that created a problem in my
office so I went in that I went in one
morning at like 6:30 and said like I
quit I said I'm gonna go back I'm gonna
build it back after you tore it down and
then I'm out of here oh now the tables
reversed though Tim and the this owner
says well what would it take to keep you
and I just thought that was WOW full
circle if you will right no one likes
you and I'm not hiring you - what will
it take to keep
you so I wrote a number on a sheet of
paper and it it was the largest son that
he'd ever guaranteed anybody and I he
agreed okay how did you come up with the
number did you already have it in your
mind before you walked into the office
no I went to quit all right well I was I
didn't know and and this is all back to
what was the starting of Keller Williams
right I had no plans to him I just you
know I'm not gonna be talked to that way
I might retreat it this way I'm not
gonna build something and then you
because you're the you're the boss that
you can just tear it down and do that
and so I was I was leaving um no I just
wrote a big I just wrote a big six
figure number that I knew he wouldn't
pay or I thought he wouldn't pay and and
then of course he paid right so I I went
out and and launched that business for
him can you say and if you can't I
understand but can you say what he did
that was so disruptive or damaging to
your office yeah it's real simple and
this is all leading up to your question
of sad we start Keller Williams yeah no
rush huh yeah so what happened was he
had a policy and guideline manual and
the policy and guideline manual for all
his offices in three cities had a clause
in it that said that if the company
changes the policy you have 48 hours to
give notice that you don't agree with
policy otherwise you're now under the
policy and so on Christmas Eve he went
to all those offices and changed a
policy about how people got paid yeah oh
that is a terrible terrible move it was
it was and in fact that policy had to do
with what happens when people leave
which I thought was really interesting
anyway so I had built this highly
successful business with literally no no
new people these were all really
seasoned vets great people and they
weren't going to take this so they left
and literally it destroyed it what he
did destroyed the office and so I went
to him and said okay I quit I'll go back
in and put it back the way it was but
when I get it there I'm out of here
and that's when he said well will it
take to keep you and I I'd wrote a
number down and he said okay I'm gonna
put you in charge of VP in charge of
expanding the company and your first job
is to go back and rebuild that business
or we're back and rebuild it and then I
got sent to another location in Austin
down south and about I would say maybe a
month and a half into that at most he
called me up out of the blue and wanted
to know what I'd done for him now
understand that my office was in an
office building in South Austin and I
was in the broom closet and I know as
the broom closet because there were
brooms in it and it did have a window
however and they gave me a folding table
for my desk a folding table for as a
credenza if you will and then they gave
me two two folding chairs and a flip
chart and a phone and said go go go
build another company well I did and had
I stayed this was within 1983 had I
stayed he owed me a huge bonus but it
was never about the money so I you know
in the end and so I just quit you know
and I didn't know what I was going to do
that's the thing I really didn't know I
just I just knew that I wasn't going to
work for someone who talked to people
that way and the other thing that was
going on in his firm whether there were
men women who had been with him a long
long time and he had promised them you
know compensation in the form of stock
or profits interest and what what was
happening was now he was taking all that
back he was undoing all of that and
trying to pull everything back into
himself and I saw the writing on the
wall because I'm looking up going well
what's my future with a guy like that
and I you know in other words I too
could work for 20 years for a guy like
that and then having pulled the rug out
and not have anything that's the way I
internalized that so I quit and my wife
at the time I had been married now for
approximately a year and a half and my
wife became his assistant and she was
already in the firm and she'd actually
had been an administrative assistant in
the firm and so
he recruited her to come work directly
for him so I the company that's right
sorry in today he called me and treat me
that way I went I went in the next day
and quit and this time I didn't name a
price I just said I'm done and I gave
him all the names of all the people I
had recruited in all the info I had on
him and it was a it was a I think
approximately it was fourteen people and
they were all terrific terrific real
estate agent prospects and I just gave
him the list if I have I'd had just
stayed a little longer he had me a huge
bonus check but I but I didn't care
about it and I walked out and there was
a gentleman that was in the commercial
area of that company called Joe Williams
and I approached to Joe and I said why
we formed two companies form a
residential you form commercial will
each owned you know fifty percent of
each and we'll go build this and the
commercial company never took off but
but the residential side took off
immediately and never lost money we had
borrowed forty four thousand dollars to
launch the business when we paid that
back in a little over a year and to this
day we have no operational debt on the
company I've never borrowed or money and
I've never taken any outside money to
build the Keller Williams we all did it
by internal cashflow and now is there
aside from having the cash flow to do
that since a lot of people in many
industries will leverage and borrow what
were the main reasons if there were
others aside from just having plentiful
cash flow for not taking on debt to try
to grow faster man that's a that's a
wonderful question
you know I'll I'll cheat and I'll give
you a quote from Robert Kiyosaki which
is assets feed me liabilities eat me and
that mantra kind of plays in my head a
little bit that if you have to borrow
money it means you can't afford what
you're fixing to buy even though that's
by the way that's not true right it's
it's not true I definitely have used
debt to buy real estate when it makes
sense I use debt when it makes sense
by a business so I'm I'm not the no debt
guy but I I do come from a position of I
want to be I want to be smart with money
such that money doesn't leave me and in
debts a way to do that so other than
that it that the reality is is that it
didn't take a lot of money to build a
real estate business because real
estate's one of the few careers where
you can come in as a job and then as you
generate more income you just get rid of
it you start shedding the jobs and it
naturally leads to a business with
employed people I don't know if that
makes sense but but you could literally
leverage your way all the way from being
a salesperson to owning a business I
contrast that to like the the people
that do the maintenance in this building
there's no natural path from being a you
know being the maintenance crew on a
building to owning the building it's not
that it's not a natural path it doesn't
lead to that but in real estate it
actually does you can literally you do
all the jobs from day one and as you
lever up and bring in other people so
you you ultimately get rid of all the
jobs so maybe that helps explain why -
Lee didn't need the capital I didn't
need it because I was I was organically
growing and generating more cash flow
and my understanding is that and you can
correct me if I'm a moth on the timeline
for this but two or so years later kW
rattler Williams is the largest office
in Austin and as as you mentioned you
don't necessarily need a lot of cash to
get started or to enter the game of real
estate so it's a very competitive it's a
very competitive industry - what do you
attribute your ability to not only
become the largest office and obviously
that's expanded to nationwide and
there's only one end worldwide what but
in that first two years let's just say
due to what do you attribute your
ability to stand out and
Grosso effectively well I understood
value so what I understood was is that
the real estate agent has the has the
relationship with the client in the real
estate brokerage company has a
relationship with the agent and I
understood exactly what the value
proposition needed to be to attract and
retain really terrific people so I
understood that and the way I like to
say it is Keller Williams was my third
business if you think about it because I
already launched two businesses for my
former boss
so you'd been learning on someone else's
dime so to speak yes absolutely the best
way to learn right so I I was intimate
I had intimate knowledge with the
financials and what it cost and I
understood how much revenue I had to
generate in order to you know cross the
hurdle into positive cash flow and so I
just do it so I set the business up that
way I kind of play a game that that I
call red light green light and meaning
that if I'm doing well
then green light keep keep keep going
that direction if something happens the
I I don't keep hitting the green light
right if something happens that should
cause me to pause in any way
particularly from a financial standpoint
then I'm gonna hit red light fast and
I'm gonna back up and ask the question
what do I need to do what did I do wrong
whatever what happened so the the the
the building of a real estate company
you can generate all the cash flow you
need to do that even in these times
right now of you know I have competitors
who have raised over a billion dollars
and are just spending the money like
crazy in the real estate space but what
I understand is it doesn't take all that
money to do that it takes smart money
more than it takes a lot of money oh for
sure
there's no certainly no lack of examples
of companies that have pissed away
millions of dollars or more I love to
hear an example if you could give one of
a time when
you saw the red light or hit the red
light and then how you did a post-game
analysis well probably the the biggest
red light that I had to hit early on was
the commercial side red light because it
never made a profit and we would
literally just take the money that I was
learning from the company I started and
hand it to the other company that was
being run by my partner he's a good guys
a great guy Joe Williams just salt of
the earth just a just a wonderful human
being but it was losing money and I hit
the red light immediately and said I'm
not going to give any more money and his
response was well how am I going to pay
the bills and my response was exactly
exactly right how are you how are you
going to pay your bills yeah and and
then he voluntarily shut the company
down within a few months that was how
did that conversation if you don't mind
me I apologize for the interruptions but
I'm very interested how did that how is
that dissolution or separation handled
this is a very common situation among
co-founders it happens all the time were
there any particular things that you
feel that you guys did right or that you
did right in handling that were there
things that you would have done
differently in retrospect actually with
between he and I know it was a it was a
it was a natural thing I had I we didn't
have an agreement that said that we had
to take one you know one pot of money
and give it to the other pot so in it
and it was amicable I mean there was no
I would say that I don't think that that
Joe and I ever had a crossword I think
that he's a he it's a testimony to him
he's just a stand-up guy and but on the
other hand I'm not going to keep putting
good money into a bad situation right
that that you can see doesn't have a
plan that it can execute successfully on
so it was really that simple there were
separate businesses and I wasn't
obligated to give the money so I just
stopped I hit the red light and I just
stopped and so it's kind of you know the
I would say if you're if you want to ask
the question of what have you learned
over
time not what did you learn from that
was that your your agreements between
you and your partners I called them
disagreement because the only time
you're gonna read it is when you
disagree so true yeah right yeah it said
in that that really informs the way you
look at a document when you call it a
disagreement because it's there too it's
it should be there to to deal with it
when you just deal with things when you
disagree otherwise if you agree you
never read the document you never go
back to it yeah that's genius
yeah that's a great way to reframe it
well in the biggest issue that I find
the biggest issues are who has control
who's who's the decision maker can that
decision maker be relieved from that if
you have to how are you going to handle
cash flow if there's profit are you
going to distribute it monthly quarterly
annually never what are you what are you
gonna do and then the other one is the
dissolution and that is what happens if
this isn't working out and one of you
needs to buy the other one out one of
the things that happened to me was so we
ended up forming this firm and an ad in
February of 84 and I'd now been married
less than three years the company was
just a little over one year old and my
my wife of that at that time said she
didn't love me and she'd never loved me
and we we headed to divorce and they
they started out at a million dollar
valuation on a one year old company that
if you took me out of it would be
worthless and I ended up negotiating my
divorce with my former boss so if you
want to read between the lines and think
about that you're welcome to do so
right I turn to my attorney and said why
am i taking the deposition of that guy
am I trying to just looked at me says
whole time will reveal all and and it
did by the way but the the agreement to
breakup right if someone passes away or
if someone wants to sell to me that
becomes one of the biggest clauses and
those agreements in and candidly
you'd be really really you know smart at
that on it at this because this is where
people go we're gonna get along we're
good friends or whatever we're going to
found a company together and they look
up later and they realize that they
don't have a disagreement they basically
have an agreement and that's so
important yeah yeah they don't have it
they have no means of reconciliation
they have no means of parting without
bankrupting the other business so what
happened to me was when it got to the
divorce I had a buy-sell agreement by
the way and it would have meant that I
would have I could have gone into my
bank account and written the check for
what I owed under the under the buy sell
agreement can you do fine for people who
don't know what that means
a buy sell agreement I'm sure this
simply means that if I'm one of the
partners and I want out what what
happens right does that there's a
document address that at all can I sell
the stock to anybody does does the
company have to buy it if the company
has to buy it or wants to buy it what
are the terms of that or are there no
terms and it's just strictly a cash deal
what happened does that make sense yeah
okay that's a that's basically a buy
sell it's a it's a pre-arranged way that
things are going to go if you decide to
part company for any reason or you need
to part company for eurozone well I had
one Tim but the judge in the case says
well okay I see you have a buy sell
agreement who represented you mr. Keller
and I said my attorney standing here he
said who represented her and I said my
attorney standing here and they threw it
out yeah yeah because we had used the
same attorney good attorney and he
hadn't cheated anybody it was a it was a
fair buy sell agreement but they they
threw it out
yeah this is I want to underscore a
couple of really really important things
that you're saying so number one is
whether it's I mean particularly I would
say in in personal relationships like a
marriage how critical it is to have
separate counsel right for the differ
that's for a million and one reasons and
then also
the a pattern that's come up in a lot of
these interviews which is from the
outside looking in many many
interviewees who are viewed as risk
takers are actually experts in capping
the downside as right and are very good
at thinking through the worst-case
scenarios and setting plans if then
plans for for the divorce proceedings or
the escape plan so to speak that's right
if those were scum this worst-case
scenarios come to pass that's exactly
right the very first thing I look at in
every contract that gets set to me
especially if there's some type of
personal guarantee or and well I'm
involved personally is the termination
clause not because I want to weasel out
of something not because I want to plan
for failure it's for all the reasons
that you just mentioned if you don't
have a plan for the disagreement which
it's it's such a smart reframe you're
dead in the water because the that's
right when you're going to need that
document is when you do not see eye to
eye or have a problem so let me tell you
a funny story or I don't know how funny
it is but so I after that divorce you
know I met the love of my life marry and
we've been married for 32 years and her
father when he was alive
her mother had passed away from cancer
many many years ago in her father was
was now getting remarried and I now
having lived this Tim I turn to my
father-in-law and said I'm getting you a
lawyer and your fiancee needs to get a
lawyer and they need to be separate and
there needs to be essentially a
prenuptial contract which is very
closely related to the buy/sell you know
right basically it's a disillusion
disillusionment agreement right so they
did they each got separate attorneys and
they did this prenuptial well fast
forward to the last year of my
father-in-law's
where he was beginning to get dementia
and he then passes away and within a few
days after him passing away we get up we
get a an envelope that in it is a
handwritten I give all my money to my
wife right I give all of my my liquid
assets to my wife and it has his
signature now at the time we didn't know
that he actually had been diagnosed with
dementia
we were unaware of that and he had
actually said just a month or so before
he died he said watch her she's going to
try to take everything and and it
happened and she and the weird thing is
is that she for that little sheet of
paper
she took a gentleman who was suffering
from dementia and she took it to her
lawyer the same one that had drawn up
her side of the prenuptial and of course
we heard a good law firm and that took
about five minutes to the law firm had
to recuse themselves and then to to
basically explain that that we would
drag this out forever
because the man had dementia and it was
documented we went back and checked and
it was documented but the spouse had
never told the kids any of that so my
little lesson turned around and paid
huge dividends for my my father-in-law
and his estate because they could not
pierce it
yep that's that's a great example and
it's very important very close friend of
mine one of his uncle's has dementia
very well documented and he's suing
other members of the family and there
are all sorts of a headache and
heartache as you as you might imagine
and yes it's very normal it's really
important for yourself and and we're
going to come back to to your story in a
second but broadly speaking to determine
who will make decisions who can make
decisions for someone else if they are
incapacity
were dead or diagnosed or something like
dementia yeah and you ever recently
helped a friend who did not have any of
this in place to figure out a way
thankfully her her parent is lucid not
and does not have dementia they just
don't didn't have the cash to set this
up beforehand but to dock to talk about
things like power of attorney documents
when things are reasonably stable so
that people can make decisions for
someone else when the time comes and
lawyers say or hospitals say show us the
documents you want to have those
beforehand so said I'd like to come back
to so once one statement about that oh
there's one you know just what one of
the lessons that I've learned Tim is
that money won't change you but it will
reveal you and when MIT when people have
an opportunity to have a financial
windfall their character is getting
ready to be revealed yes completely
consistent with my observations as well
and having it and having a document
whether it be you know with loved you
know helping loved ones protect
themselves or in business it actually is
it's it's really important people have
asked me over the years about Keller
Williams and and what's important about
it and I I always give the same answer
and that is our most important asset is
our franchise document which is a
massive disagreement sits let's actually
I'm gonna I'm gonna feed to my my
earlier pivot and and talk about that
for a second because I want to spend a
good amount of time talking about focus
because you are famous for your ability
to focus but before we get to that
you're talking about this franchise
document and I know very little about
real estate but a a friend of mine when
I was doing prep for this said they you
redefined franchising through regional
ownerships
and then he went on to say how the
companies
more money year on year since they
started in 85 I think at one point is
like forty percent per year for a decade
or something I mean really incredible
growth but could you talk about so you
have the franchise document you you also
innovated in terms of model as I
understand it what is redefined
franchising through regional ownerships
mean it was accurate yeah yeah
so you actually asked a couple of
questions I know that it's my the
tendency no no I just want it so let's
talk about that regional so when we when
we as a company we're ready to go out of
out of state if you will we we began to
study how others had done it and we
discovered that in the real estate
industry and in other industries as well
that the at the time they they did
what's called master franchises so
franchising remembers is just another
vehicle a financial vehicle right if you
don't have the money franchise and ask
other people to come in and front the
cost that it would have been had you
employed them so that's that's one of
the ways you keep from having to borrow
money understand is is you could use
franchising and he Sencha use other
people's money
I had actually expanded into four cities
and all of them did great as long as I
showed up and then and then when I
didn't show up they all started failing
so I took a year off in 89 and one of
the things in and began to document the
business and because the there's an
incredible story about the McDonald's
brothers and and behind the golden
arches that really just changed my my
world and one of them was around
franchising and the other one was about
building a successful model and the
franchising part was that we looked into
it and we discovered that the way that
franchising had been done was flawed and
that was called the master franchise
approach so Dairy Queen was a perfect
example
so Dairy Queen at one time was like you
know the kick butt tech name fast food
place in America and what they had done
is they had
the the the rights for the franchises
the what you would call the the regional
franchises to then be the franchisor of
the franchisees so the print company
wasn't we all it was franchising was you
know these regional businesses to then
go and they would sell franchises and
they would support franchises okay just
to restate so I understand so you might
have like arbitrarily let's just say cut
the country into four quadrants you have
four digital people those are your only
kind of direct reports who pay you and
then they have a downline of sorts where
they then go out but you're only
interacting with those you only have
agreements with those four regional
franchisees who then become franchisee
drawers meaning they're granting these
licenses to other people that's right
and it's called sub franchising and and
I so I read the Dairy Queen story
because when McDonald's came out with
their playground that was actually an
amazing value hack right I mean they
they they they realized that if they
could get the kids wanting to come to
McDonald's the parents you know would
take them right and there's a playground
so there was a famous meeting where the
these master franchise words if you will
the sub franchisor met and I know how
many there were in it but they met and
they decided that they didn't want to do
the playgrounds this is for their four
Dairy Queen or affirming a hospital area
so McDonald's was doing it and and and
really you know making inroads fast and
so Dairy Queen calls a meeting and says
hey we needed our franchisees need to be
putting in playgrounds and the sub
franchisor was the regional people said
no not going to do it and by the way
that was the beginning of Dairy Queen
sliding into a much smaller company than
they could have been and they never they
never really recovered from that so I
read that and I my my
my plan then was I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna repeat that so we did it we did
what's called a regional representative
agreement so the financial opportunity
is the same so we have 31 regions in the
US and Canada and those are owned by
individuals and but they're not sub
franchise ORS they are simply
representatives so they have the same
job description of a sub franchise they
have the same financial opportunity of a
sub franchise they don't have the
authority mm-hmm and I would imagine the
franchise document that you have
prevents the type of logjam if you were
to say we want to install playgrounds at
the in your offices metaphorically
speaking in those thirty-one the home
office has the ability to insist let's
let's say on certain types of things
that they wouldn't run into the same
type of Dairy Queen problem we have
that's that's that's right without
having to go into the weeds on documents
you said that very well the the document
lays out the rights of the franchisor
and the reason is because if there is if
a right isn't acknowledged in that
document the judge will automatically
give it to the franchisee yeah if it's
if it's an unstated right then the
courts will take it away so you it's not
if it's not explicitly assigned to you
kW the franchisee or it will be you know
in a vacuum of mention in the document
automatically assigned to the franchisee
every time yeah every time so when
people read a franchise document if they
don't say heck no I'm not signing this
it's an intelligence test they that
should be your first reaction what I
explained to them is that this is a
disagreement and that the the odds are
pretty strong that anything we don't
address here as my rights become your
rights by default so this is gonna this
is going to read like the most one-sided
agreement you've ever seen but I just
want you to realize that anything that
is uncovered in this document
automatically goes to you and you are
the decider so so that was that's that
that was the the the the regional side
of that story then the other side of the
McDonnells behind the golden arches that
just really profoundly impacted me was
the story of the French frys do you know
that story I don't know if I know the
story I watched well I watched the movie
with Birdman I'm blanking on the on the
actor's name beetlejuice somebody will
Michael Keaton but I I haven't I don't
have any background beyond that so this
is a great story and it it hit me like a
ton of bricks when I read it and I'm
just gonna paraphrase and tell it to you
as if it's a bedtime story
but please so yeah so this guy ray kroc
this is kept this is Keller all the way
right so Ray Kroc he hears about these
McDonald's brothers and they people line
up you know around the block to to get
their food and he's a Salesman and so he
wants to go down and meet with them and
understand their secrets so he can go
back and take it to his to his customer
so then they could order more Dixie Cups
and whatever he was selling them he got
down there and was enamored with them
and in house could he franchise and it
was a tough it was a tough negotiation
they ultimately allowed him he goes back
to Illinois he builds out the stuff that
he needs to build out in order to be
able to you know deliver stores that
sell food exactly like the McDonald's
brothers and the challenge was the
french fries didn't taste right so he
calls the McDonald's brothers and and
says you know tell me what we did wrong
or whatever and nobody could figure it
out so what McDonald's did and I love
this phrase they suspended their need to
understand and they went and they went
all the way back to where they bought
the potato and they documented they
tracked and documented all the steps
from the from the field to the table
and they discovered yeah and they
discovered when they discovered
something and that is the McDonald
brothers had not invented a way to cook
a french fry
they had stumbled on a way to cure a
potato what was happening the step that
the McDonald's brothers never told Ray
Kroc was that when they got the potatoes
they put him in open-air burlap sacks
and in the climate where the McDonald's
operated when you put potatoes in an
open-air burlap sack in that temperature
the potato cures amazing and then oh by
the way you can cook it any way you want
it tastes great and so that by the way
so just into the story so Ray Kroc went
back to to Illinois he duplicated the
curing process in the rest is history
that's incredible so this then brings us
back to the year off in 89 I have a
bunch of questions about that so 89
paint a picture for how the business is
doing because I'm sure a lot of people
are thinking to themselves man I'd love
to take a year off my business is hectic
how in the hell did karyam take year off
in 89 how did you decide to do that was
there straw that broke the camel's back
and then practically still looking yeah
how do okay so let's let's keep me on
track here but I want to go I want to go
back and I want to I want to build to
that to the moment of 89 so you'll
understand what happened so in so we
launched in in 80 in the last quarter of
83 I end up in February of 84 becoming
you know going through a divorce and and
now I am in debt because I I had to say
I didn't have the cash right to sign a
note and then I had taken an insurance
policy in case I died my former spouse
got paid and then within a year Joe
Williams came in and said he has to sell
his shares in the residential company
we'd already shot the other one down
commercial down but he needed to sell
his shares because he'd bought a lot of
real estate the markets this is now 87
right this is 88 the mark
it's are crashing and he doesn't want to
go bankrupt and he didn't to his credit
he did not just a stand-up guy but he
came to me and said hey I need to sell
the shares so all of a sudden I ain't
have the cash so I have to sign a note
to the banks take out another insurance
policy so essentially whether I live or
die everyone's going to get their money
that makes sense it makes sense yeah and
the way I kind of describe it way
particularly when I'm talking to kids is
that it was like I'd been going through
life hopping you know seven feet and
fell in a 10-foot hole and the this is
this that that like there has become the
central theme of my life since that
happened because I'd been going through
life and competing as a businessperson
in a sort of organic progressive way in
other words it's the next thing I should
do so I do there I go there but I wasn't
on an exponential path in other words I
wasn't running my business out of a
business plan that would deliver
exponential growth I was living off of
an organic plan and I look down and I
realize oh my gosh
it's gonna take me ten years under this
current you know earnings path I'm on
maybe sooner but not much before I'm
debt free and that depressed the heck
out of me and so I got really created
then then one last thing happened then
one of my competitors with a Remax
office set up shop down the street and
they were a lot less expensive than what
we did and I had five of my top ten
producers leave the firm and and I had
grown to over 70 associates the the
economy going down took me to 38
associates we were still profitable
nicely profitable and then I lost five
at the top of the top ten and so now I'm
at 33 associates and then they came back
and they got my bookkeeper my
receptionist in my relocation
coordinator and that sounds like a
really hard 12 to 18 month period
yeah absolutely so what so now I just
want to set the stage for 89 so now
what's happened is I'm indebted to my
eyeballs the market is crashing right
and my competitors are taking my people
so I'm literally sitting at the desk
with no one no one to run the business
other than me and I'm in desperate need
of a plan that would actually help me
hop higher and so I created that plan
and one year later we were the largest
real estate company in Austin and when
the next year we sold more real estate
than anyone and the next year after that
I paid everybody off in cash and I would
I was I was I was 31 years old I was um
towards the end of 31 by the way I paid
everyone off in cash I was debt free and
I was the number one real estate company
in my city so that plan was the plan you
drafted during your year off is that
right or no no that's not so separate
issues I was a separate issue
it's a separate issue so the so the the
plan is what ultimately created a model
that I could go teach other people and I
could franchise that model so this so
then let's go to 80 88 87 88 so I go
around the state of Texas and I'm
showing how I'm doing business and
people are buying at that time license
agreement because I wasn't franchising
at the time so they bought license
agreements and the agreement said if I
ever franchise you have to come become a
franchisee or have the right to buy your
business
what is that could you clarify what the
differences of Licensing they're paying
a percentage just to use your name yep
and that's it and your licensing to use
your name and systems but you don't
really have any control or influence I
see with the light with the license
versus franchising so the so I was using
a simple license agreement well I was I
was literally traveling four days a week
right if it was Monday I'm in San
Antonio if I'm in Houston it's Tuesday I
mean that I was living my life that way
and and all the businesses that we
launched were were successful and
profitable in me I'm thinking I'm a
genius oh I I come home and then they
all fail
and so what I did was I did two things
number one is I hired an individual and
that individual this is now now we're
getting to eighty nine okay so I then I
then take that year off if you will I'm
not franchising I'm not licensing I'm
not doing anything
I've hired a manager to run my Austin
operation so I have the freedom and I
hired a gentleman and gave him a video
recorder a an audio recorder notebook
and pin and a camera and I said I want
you to follow me around and I'm going to
go launch another office and I want you
to document every little thing that I do
that is brilliant with no that's the
that's the French frys story yeah that
was like that yeah so I read the French
frys story about that time and then I
said okay so my firt another one thing
I'm going to do is I'm gonna do that the
second thing I'm going to do is so I'm
going to create an operating man set of
manuals that that absolutely show how to
launch it how to run it right and and
the second thing I did was I discovered
a list of the top Tim franchise
attorneys in the country and I started
interviewing and I ended up hiring this
amazing individual out of Dallas and she
was the one she was her who said you do
not want to master franchise you want to
read you want to use a regional
representative approach now answers to
clarify at the time were you
interviewing them to potentially be your
attorney or are you interviewing them
and paying them for their time as part
of your research I actually hired them
to help me build a franchise document
the lawyer and and she and then she came
back and said you don't you don't want
to do what the others do so the way we
built our document was we we wouldn't
got our hands on our competitors
documents and we got our hands on
McDonald's document and then we took
them by sections so we we created I
don't think I think I was like 19
manuals and each manual had how each of
these franchisor wars dealt with issue
number one
the next manual was how they dealt with
issue number two the third manual was
how they all dealt so I now can pick up
manual one and I can see how all these
franchise ORS have dealt with that issue
in their document and with Joyce's
guidance we went through and made
decisions chapter by chapter if you will
on how we wanted to build our franchise
if that makes sense
this makes sense yeah so we came out so
by the way so at the end of 89 by the
way I I did spend all my money I just
want to be clear that hiring that that
attorney said that she gave me a bid to
build that document at $100,000 she quit
billing me that's how expensive the
document was it was it's a serious
document and yeah absolutely
so then I take this document and I take
the house for one second so your second
hundred thousand dollars how much money
do you think that document has saved you
excluding the headache and heartache and
I will assure you it is the most
valuable asset of the company it hands
down it's the most valuable asset
there's no there's not even a close
second it is it is the it is the key
asset so I went back so now I take all I
take these manuals and I take the
franchise document go back to Houston I
meet this lovely individual who sadly
just passed away last year but this is
1989 and so I go back signer up I give
her a two-week training program and then
I leave and I hold my breath and go come
on
sevens right I mean it's it's I'm
holding my breath because I'm not coming
back right I can't scale this thing if I
have to go do it
I can only scale it if others can follow
the model and she did real well and that
is a hugely successful business today
in fact it's funny that her she had told
her son that that that I had basically
saved her life and when my when my son
was real little
marry my wife and our son were in a
grocery store here in Austin in this
franchisee happened to be here visiting
her sister and they ran into her to
grocery store and my wife tells me that
she got down on her knees to stare at my
little boy and proceeded to tell him
though he couldn't comprehend a word she
was saying how when I did had had
changed her life so anyway so that's the
story of 89
the story of 89 was I took a year off
and I reinvented how I did business and
I basically created the platform if you
want to call it that for building a
nationwide real estate franchise what a
story
yeah thank you for telling that I I want
to talk about the flipped shirt that you
mentioned at the beginning of the
conversation when you're in the broom
closet
so you k'kaw is very heavily investing
in technology it's it's in many respects
becoming a technology company yet my
understanding is you still use a pay per
month at a glance calendar and a pencil
what what is it the story behind that
you know the I believe that and I didn't
always believe this right it's it's you
learn as as you you go and if you learn
you grow right and I I'm I'm I'm having
trouble visualizing my life and I get
this month at a glance and
instantaneously I can see where all my
energy this month is going I can see how
I'm investing my life and so I I begin
this practice back in my 20s of using
this month at a glance and I can see
everything at one time right and I use
an eraser because if you erase you must
replace so I go through the month and I
kind of Mark you know what I what I
think I should be doing on these days in
order to hit my personal and
professional and financial goals
and I'm happy to erase if I need to but
by doing it this way if it was important
to do it I can't you can't disappear I
have to move it someplace else in my
calendar so it's really a simple this
the simple idea that I don't I don't I
really struggle with the idea of doing
planning off of a technology-based day
timer for that reason only I'll tell you
a funny story there's a there's a guy by
the name of Larry Bragg and he was the
lead singer for tower power and I didn't
know him personally but I was coming
back from Vegas on a trip and I'd gotten
to the Southwest Airlines you know gate
early and there was only one guy in
front of me and I recognized him as the
lead singer of tower power then I looked
down and he had a briefcase and it had a
tag that said tower power on it right
anyway okay I'm pretty see I'm pretty
sure this is Larry right so I say excuse
me you know I just introduced myself and
we had a great talk because I just seen
them perform a year earlier in Austin
and so we had a great conversation
somehow we turned to kenny loggins was
coming to Austin to a concert and in a
venue that that that that we loved and
in support and and Larry and I came out
in and Larry used to had sung with Kenny
Loggins and loved him and he said man
I'd like to catch that show my family's
still there and I said wait I can I can
I can get you in he said well what date
is that and I knew the date off the top
of my head and I said it and then he
pulls out his electronic calendar and
starts going through it and I went ho ho
hold it you you've gone to the dark side
and he's a laugh and he's going what do
you mean I said
okay let's have let's have a gunfight at
the OK Corral you put your phone back
down and I'll lay my calendar out here
and when when I say go on I'll go 1 2 3
go
when I say go we both reach for our guns
and see who's the first one who can
shoot they just looked at me and that's
it let's do it let's see what happens so
he says ok so I go 1 2 3 go
I just pick up my calendar pull it open
and go there it is and he's still trying
to get into his phone right and then I
said and oh by the way I can tell you
what I'm doing tomorrow at 3 o'clock I
can tell you what I'm doing two weeks
from now I can tell you I did everything
I did last week and I'm just I'm just
peppering him with my vision for my life
and he's still fumbling trying to get to
the to see if he could even go to the
concert which he did by the way and it
was awesome and he and Kenny hung out
afterwards where does your month
etiquette Lance calendar live is it
something that you're right in front of
me is it in your on your wall in your
office is it
no no I care no I carry it with me carry
it with at all times everywhere it never
leaves my side actually it's in my
backpack but I created a I created kind
of a daily worksheet so as the day is
going on I don't actually need my
calendar per se right because I'm
working off of that but the second that
I need to do planning I got to get back
to a month I have to see the month and
if I can flip easily and look at the
other months right and for me when I'm
planning out time off and vacations and
other things it really helps for me to
see the spacing of my life to see the
things that I'm doing that give me
energy
to see the things that take energy away
from me so that I can always I can
always be fine-tuning my life but I quit
quickly at a glance so anyway it's just
a it's a really good it's a good way to
do it it does fly in the face of you
know the way that other people look at
time and using electronics or digital
time management systems but I just can't
get rid of it because it makes me it
makes me so aware of my life yeah I
think that I think that's really
important to understand it's not just
about the if the
efficiency and speed it's about the
awareness that it cultivates no it's
actually all that's the speed was just a
funny joke that happened but it really
is more about my ability to see
everything at a glance and it's easy for
me then to see how many times in you
know in the last 30 days or looking
forward to the next 30 days I have
planned right to to knock in the day to
go to lunch with my son right I can I
can actually see it I can add it up and
show you quickly at a glance I can say
well we did that three times last month
this month looks like we have a plan for
five bla bla bla bla bla so give for me
personally it gives me great vision if
you will and so I could I can manage my
energy and I can always make sure that I
have enough time set aside for the
things that really matter and I can see
that better at a glance when I'm looking
at a bigger picture and that's the only
that's the value that's the only value
let's let's talk a little bit about
spacing two things you mentioned spacing
and energy I don't know if you still
think about treating your time like
going to the movies this is something I
came across which I thought was very
helpful as a comparison could you could
you speak to what you mean by that
oh well that one is about time blocking
so yeah yeah so that it in the I'll just
speak for myself
um the it is very hard to have a perfect
day every day and as as the research
will tell you that will power is on will
call right it's not you don't have a
steady stream of willpower when you wake
up in the morning and it doesn't matter
what time and if you got up at 6 if you
got up at noon
when you wake up this these are your
power hours and I used to tell people
look the goal is to have a great day by
noon in other words get everything did
everything that matters
that is important to you get it done
don't put it off get it done and then
let the events of the morning drive your
afternoon and so time blocking is just
this idea of you pre-planning your time
because if you needed to exercise then
and that's what you want to do you've
got to find the time to do it and then
you're gonna have to block that out the
the movie analogy was was this idea that
you don't really need to time block more
than two or three hours a day around
your your core activity for your
business whatever that is you don't
you're not equally effective all day
long so what you want to do is you want
to find that you want to make sure that
the world doesn't infringe on the time
that you've that that you know you need
to give for whatever it is is the key
that makes your professional life run
and so I I just time block and then I
encourage it go ahead no I was just
gonna say and those two to three hours
are like a film right I mean if that is
your if you go to see a movie you are
there exclusively to see a movie so you
turn off your cell phone you get snacks
in case you're hungry you might make a
pit stop in the bathroom beforehand you
do all of that so it can be you can have
an uninterrupted two to three hours
that's it that's exactly you said it
perfectly that's exactly what it is and
it's it's kind of wild to think how much
if I look back at periods when I've been
able to time block that way successfully
consistently and by consistently I mean
even for two weeks
how much can get done if you set aside
the equivalent of one movie two
single-task on one important thing it's
it's really remarkable and I think
that's a perhaps a good segue to the
focusing question right and this is this
is in your book the one thing which has
come up over and over and over again
with interviewees on this podcast
particularly those who are in the sort
of growth phase and citing it as
extremely important in the first it's
always important I mean this question
but the particularly important in the
kind of make or break it years in the
first handful of years for entrepreneurs
that I've interviewed on that plan yes
could you tell us about the focusing
question but perhaps how you got to the
focusing question you know the so fruits
if we just talk for a second about the
focusing question right which is what's
the one thing I can do such that by
doing it everything is is either easier
or unnecessary it's it's it's an
understanding that you can't do two
important things at the same time you
can you could set definitely multitask
but the second that something really
matters to you a lot you don't multitask
you you you you hone in on that and you
you you do that thing so that the the
idea of the focusing question is are you
present in the moment now you don't do
this every day minute by minute where
you say well was it important thing I
could do right now what's the one thing
I can do right now what's the one thing
I can do right now but it is kind of a
way of life meaning that if you make
your moments matter right matter as in
you your appropriate in the right moment
every every everything falls into place
for you
so the whole idea behind the focusing
question was to keep when it matters
when it's important to you making sure
that that you're doing the priority
right now that will lever your life grow
your life expand your life right and in
its the it's the idea that if you you
know if two people are standing in the
same spot and one has a clear focus and
understands the thing they need to be
doing right now in order to get where
they want to go there's their next step
is an appropriate step for the
individual who doesn't know what they
should do they're they're most likely
going to take the wrong step and then
another wrong step and another wrong
step and over time there they are worlds
apart
the everything that we talked about from
calendars to setting goals to creating
plans all of that is to is so that you
get one thing and that is in the moment
right now you're doing the thing that
matters most such that by doing it what
you're fixing to do next will either be
easier or could turn out to be
unnecessary and so I want to I want to
comment on a few things here first is
for people who are maybe in the in
Portugal listening to this fixin to do
some things getting ready to do it and
the the second is how powerful this
question is and how important the
phrasing is what's the one thing I could
do such that by doing it everything else
would be easier or unnecessary because
Ana and then I'd love to just hear you
kind of riff on this but II a lot of
people listening to this and I'll plead
guilty myself also very often end up
with a to-do list which is this
spontaneously generated yep
non-hierarchical yep brain splatter of
yep tasks and you know I'm a then just
proceed in a given day if you don't give
any thought to it to start knocking
those off in order top to bottom even
though they're not ordered in terms of
importance and the such that it makes
everything else easier or unnecessary is
the key right because you're finding
that lead Domino that kind of knocks
everything else over and in that I'd
love to to hear maybe some of the
results or effects that you've seen in
your life as a result of of using this
or for your company for that matter but
like how do you suggest people to use
this do they think about it for the week
and then set something to remind them on
a daily basis that you do with them the
night before and then write it down
what's the protocol for actually
implementing this
well remember it and we said it in the
title of the book and that is the
surprisingly simple truth behind
extraordinary results so this is in my
mind the concept of the one thing is
like adult Plato it's it's it's a this
is a new clear idea it is a an
extraordinary idea in order to get
extraordinary results if you're
inappropriate in the moment the next
moment you have not set up to succeed so
you're behind right and so we have to be
appropriate in our moments so and I
think I understand and I've always
understood that naturally to be honest
but I think at some point and I couldn't
pinpoint it my I grabbed it as an idea
and began to aim my life around that and
so simple ways to think about it is I
come home I pull in the garage what's
the one thing I could do with my wife
when I walk in the door says there by
doing it everything else for the rest of
the night will be easier or unnecessary
and the answer is go find her and kiss
her that's the answer and it's actually
that simple on a weekend what's the one
thing I can do such that by doing it
everything else would be easier or
unnecessary so the one thing is is I
wake up in the morning and make a quick
list of things I need to do around the
house and I do that because I know that
my wife is going to make a list for me
and so the one thing I can do sister by
doing it my weekend is is better is to
make that list and go knock it out
that's the right thing right the my dog
what's the one thing I can do with my
dog in the morning such that by doing it
everything else is easier unnecessary by
the way they answer with our dog Millie
is always the same get on the floor and
hug her right that's what she wants and
as long as I do that life is great if I
don't do that well everything else is
irrelevant to the dog she wants just
wants me to love her so I'm just giving
you a variety of
different ways right what's the one
thing I could do with my diet such that
by doing it everything else would be
easier unnecessary what's the one thing
I can do that affects my cholesterol
affects my heart it affects everything
about me
right and for me is the one thing is eat
vegetarian mm-hmm so that becomes the
one thing for me so I'm just giving you
a variety of different of different ways
of thinking oh this is and just to
comment on the last one too as you know
eat vegetarian and part of that I would
imagine is setting up your environments
that you require less willpower right so
you just get rid of anything that is not
compliant with that that is in your
house that you decide that Aryan or
something else that makes everything
else easier or unnecessary like self
control in looking at a box of whatever
it is you're not supposed to eat that's
staring in the face when you open your
refrigerator so in business it would go
like a good example of using this would
be in my business who's the one person I
could hire assisted by hiring them
hiring other people would be unnecessary
or easier how if you how might you have
answered that for yourself in the past
well in 1994 I answered it by firing
myself and hiring a CEO because I'm
asking the question what's the one thing
I could do right now such that by doing
it everything else would be easier
unnecessary in growing the company and
the answer was firing myself and hire
somebody better suited right now at that
moment in the history to do that and
then I ask the question okay so I
understand hiring now is my one thing
then the question becomes who's the one
person I can hire accessible hiring them
everything else becomes easier and
necessary so then I go on a hunt for
that person who when I hire them I
believe they can fulfill what I just
said it becomes the one hire if that
makes sense
it does yeah and and one go ahead same
with technology right in in moving the
in moving the organization from being a
company that buys technology to a
company that builds as technology which
is the distinction between being a tech
company and not right you can't be a
weird
tech company we buy all our tech you're
not a tech company tech company builds
tech right so then the question becomes
what's the one tech product you can
build such that by building everything
else is easier unnecessary and we played
the game is this is there's a there's a
line in the one thing that that I really
like and I'd love to hear how you think
about or how you suggest people how you
could elaborate on it perhaps a clear
path to a lesser goal is the problem is
is one of the lines that I have jotted
down here and I mean the way that I sort
of interpret that is at least for myself
personally is that it's it's not the
sort of terrible ideas it's not the
awful propositions and opportunities
that are the problem past a certain
point and it comes pretty early for a
lot of folks and a lot of people
listening it's these sort of kind of
cool easy to commit to opportunities
that are actually more threats and
temptations than opportunities they have
the biggest threat to the one thing that
you might decide if you ask that
question that we've been talking about
is that the right way to think about a
clear path to a lesser go being the
problem I think so yeah I think that the
do one of the things that I I think it
surprises people when they find out that
I'm not focused all day long that in
other words my goal is to have a really
great day by noon and then if I if I
want to be distracted or can be
distracted that's fine it doesn't really
matter I've already done everything that
mattered I've done the thing that
mattered the most we're gonna drive
right which is really really is that
it's kind of the cousin of the 80/20
rule right for sure so that's all it is
and then the way Jay and I described it
in in our book we're just saying that
that the one thing is the 80/20
principle on steroids right it's on it's
it's on it's a new clear way of looking
at prioritizing and just just
doing it in in the other side of that is
is that it all comes down to the fact
that you have to live in the moment and
so the question is are you living
appropriately or not mm-hmm and then the
other issue is do you always have to do
that you always have to fight off
distraction and my response to that is
heck no what what you need to do is
protect yourself so you know you need I
put forth this idea that the morning is
the best time for you to deal with your
energy so I just recommend that people
get up and have pretty much a set
routine when they get up in the morning
to ensure that they get the key things
in their personal life nailed that you
then go to work and you you just do that
work what is the thing that's most
important today and do that and in the
afternoon if you still want to pursue
lesser goals or other things who cares
it's not going to impact your success
mm-hmm so you don't have to be this
hundred percent always on focus yeah
it's a huge relief in the respect right
it's it's not like you have to maximize
every minute of every day from Monday to
Friday it I'd be horrible wouldn't yep
yeah it would be horrible I mean it
would be I don't even know how anybody
would do that I mean a horrible life so
the point is is that we don't want to be
this is just me talking for me but my
life is better when I'm spontaneous
after I've done my most important thing
that that being spontaneous before that
that's where it becomes a distraction
and does me harm
so I'm free to pursue all kind of
trivial pursuits after I've done what
matters most because it just doesn't
matter right it you know is if you like
it you'll want to do it do it it's not
going to harm you because tomorrow
morning you're gonna wake back up and
you're going to be focused again from
the time you get up until about noon or
whatever it is whatever there whatever
time you get up that's six hours that
that five and half hours where that is
that's that's your power time that's
where that's where you take over the
world be great for the that length of
time
and you're good to go one of the most
popular highlights this is from
Goodreads from the one thing is quote
work is a rubber ball if you drop it it
will bounce back the other four balls
family health friends integrity are made
of glass if you drop one of these it
will be irrevocably scuffed Nick perhaps
even shattered and that alludes to the
fact that there are categories of
activities or different
I wouldn't say silos because they they
certainly interact so much but areas in
your life where you can ask the focusing
question how do you think about ordering
them if there is an order that's a great
question I kind of order it this way
I'll um pin their spiritual physical
right mental I like I lumped those into
this category and in my personal
relationships and I lump all of that
into one category and my goal in the
morning is to make sure that that works
in other words that I get those things
done
that's what Matt's what matters most to
me because if you know if you don't take
care of your health that's like a glass
ball that shatters it's it's it's hard
to recover from that ignore your family
too long and you'll lose your family so
right and and so I kind of see spiritual
mental physical and and key
relationships as the most important
things that that matter to me in the
morning so that I'm you know that I live
by kind of a mantra that says I don't
want to die of regret right I'd right I
want to say on my deathbed if I'm even
coherent then I'm glad I did not I wish
I had right ant right does that make
sense
makes perfect sense so by the way I
played that game with my mom she was a
pistol after Dad died and I kind of
became the man in her life
and she was a pistol she was difficult
at times mom if you're hearing this you
were difficult
yeah and but a lot but loved her dearly
but she was difficult and so I had to
play the game I had to say what's the
one thing I can do with my mom says to
by doing it everything else is your
necessary because my mom would would I
don't want to go into the details of all
that but but she you know she could go
off on tangents and do things and say
things that could be hurtful and harmful
so I asked that question and the one
thing was play dominoes with my mother
mm-hmm
so for the rest of her life with few
exception I was I would go I would go to
lunch or early dinner one day a week and
I would play dominoes with my mom and
you'd be surprised because what I know
what she loved it number two it kept her
preoccupied she had to stay focused on
trying to beat me instead of talking
instead of instead of verbally beating
me up right yeah and then and then and
after I did that that went so well I
said okay now what's the one thing I
could do right what's the next Domino
and mother loved basketball so I bought
her the NBA channel every year and made
sure that she had the printed laminated
copy of the of the game schedule you
know with her right there by her easy
chair and and then we made basketball
the the thing that we talked about
because if we didn't talk about
basketball Tim we were talking about my
sisters or my spouse her sisters in a
negative during the POA very destructive
and I just I just kept away from that
with mom because I just played the game
what's the one thing I can do what's the
thing what's the one activities dominoes
what's the one thing we could talk about
basketball right so that's kind of
that's and to me that's the the the
that's just a another way of thinking
about the one thing I think that you
know I'm embarrassed to admit I've it's
so sensible and I've never applied this
question exactly as you're describing it
to individual people it makes perfect
sense and relationships with those
people I but I've never applied it
that's I think that's really
be really powerful for a lot of people
listening certainly I'm gonna do it
probably today or tomorrow sit down with
a journal so the thing is like after I
exercise I ask the question what's the
one thing I could eat or drink such as
if i doing it right everything else is
easier unnecessary and i play that game
when do you exercise what what time of
day how many times a week so I exercise
five days a week
I exercise in the morning so I get up
and by 6:30 at the latest my goal is to
be in the gym and so I do I do my cardio
right in my 20 to 30 minutes in my
target heart rate zone but I but I do
you know four minutes on in one minute
slow four minutes on one minute slow
right and I do that because the if you
exercise at a steady pace instead of
doing the high-intensity interval
training hit write HIIT that the the
arteries if you go at the same speed
your art your training your artery to be
more more brittle and rigid but if you
train your artery through high intensity
interval training with cardio and
weights you're you're going fast then
slow fast and slow and you're in your
artery is contracting expanding
contracting expanding so when I when I
get up I go right in there and I do my
twenty to thirty minutes in my target
heart rate zone and then I move to wait
and so we have a very specific schedule
clarence bass is kind of like my
physical hero
do you know Clarence I you know I know
Clarence not personally but only because
I saw his black-and-white photographs in
old the muscle and fitness magazines and
so on yeah and I would always think to
myself how on earth because he had this
thick shiny bald bulbous head kind of
like I know I now have and I would think
to myself how on earth does that old guy
so ripped just not credible eda find so
that's that is all I know of Clarence
best well that's his one thing by the
way
uh right he was it was a health and
fitness still his health and fitness
journalist but he used his body as proof
that what he was writing and talking
about actually worked but I only use it
as an example that I believe that we
have the opportunity of life to choose
our profits and most crumpets with a pH
yeah yeah and most people tend to think
of that as religion only but you could
have a profit or you can call it a
mentor or role model I just call it a
profit right but you can have you could
everyone should have the individual that
is kind of their guru for those things
right who's your health guru who do you
listen to who's lived before you right
and Jack LaLanne it's just as an example
Jack LaLanne and Clarence bass or two
perfect examples gentleman that started
bodybuilding or taking care just taking
care of their body at a very young age
when the thinking was one way and as the
thinking has changed over time both of
those men changed the way they thought
right and Jack LaLanne was incredibly
prescient I mean he was so ahead of the
curve on many things that then became
mainstream and scientifically oh yeah or
did it's it's wild also quite a
character Eddy where he would wear that
kind of crazy onesie jumpsuit and he
would say sure you don't have to
exercise but on the days you don't
exercise you're not allowed to eat I
mean very uncompromising which is
awesome yeah so so then let's ask that
question so who's the one person that
you could follow for your health such
that by doing that following anyone else
would be easier or unnecessary yeah yeah
that's great so if you don't ask the
focusing question around the people in
your life you'll end up following too
many people so again how many how many
prophets do you need around health right
if you if you just follow Jack LaLanne
right whose goal was to live to a
hundred mmm what a loser he died at 96
right but Clarence bass has the same
goal so if you if you if you wanted to
live to a hundred just let's just pick
that as a target I want to live to at
least 100 then what's the one thing you
could do
that would make that easier on
everything else easier or necessary in
my mind it would be go follow go find
the person that that exemplifies that
better than anyone else and make that
one person your TrueNorth was fun you
could it you can even go you could then
go dive into the Jack LaLanne approach
or the Clarence bass approach or whoever
is your prophet for health and you would
you could then distill down what they do
right into one thing believe it or not
and you can also this is something that
I do in in a few areas just ask yourself
for instance my friend Matt Mullenweg is
one of the calmest people under fire
I've ever witnessed in any capacity of
any age he's a young guy but incredibly
calm when making high-stakes decisions
or or facing tough circumstances and I
tend not to be that I mean I think I'm
reasonably calm but I also as my mom
would say patience has never been your
strong suit and so I will ask when I
feel myself getting spun up sometimes
upset against upset about something that
I know in many cases is trivial I'll
just ask myself what would Matt do yeah
exactly
and you can do that for ya Wayne or
whoever you choose in it if you have
seven people as your TrueNorth you don't
have a true north right it's nice right
it's scattered and it's you really need
at least I do that specific person in
that image and guess what if it doesn't
cover a hundred percent of all decisions
who cares is it as long as you have one
who helps you to navigate the majority
of decisions you're far better off yes
that's it I couldn't have said it better
that is exactly right the and people
tend to not understand that that
actually is is life-affirming its life
expanding it's it's the it's really the
if you want to live the biggest life
possible then ask big questions of
yourself right and go and go find
individuals who in fact have have
they're doing that thing that matters to
you not that not that I know what the
actual Elaine's morals were or anything
like that
need to know because I'm not saying he's
my prophet in morals I'm simply saying
he's my prophet around health and we've
been discussing up to this point
primarily how to say yes to the right
things and it's it's not necessarily a
long list but how to hone in and say yes
to the right things do you say no
categorically to anything across the
board
are there any decisions that you've made
along the lines I've I'm not going to do
X and I'll give you a personal example
just because I find it incredible how
stress removing these things these types
of categorical decisions have been for
me so I used to stress about this is
probably 2008-2009 speaking engagements
I didn't particularly enjoy speaking
engagements generally sometimes I did
and I found myself traveling all over
the place it was similar to your travel
schedule right the four days a week like
one day in Houston one day in San
Antonio etc and furthermore because I
didn't have any strict policies because
I never expected to be invited to speak
before in the first book I found myself
and my assistants constantly negotiating
one-off deals and then one of my friends
said to me who is who does next to no
public appearances he said yeah I have a
simple rule I either do do full retail I
never negotiate they pay my list price
or it's a no-go
or I do unpaid for groups and causes I
care about he said I do nothing in
between
I never negotiate and if and he said if
someone pays me an absurdly high rate
that becomes my new high-water mark
right like that becomes the new retail
price and I remember coming away from
the call thinking that is so simple and
so profound and I implemented that and
it just removed this gigantic energy
suck for me and so I've started to make
more rules like that right and I'm
curious if you have anything you
categorically just decline
pretty much everything no I know I know
it sounds a little weird to say that but
if the people around me would probably
confirm that yeah that essentially
anything that's a distraction or
anything that interferes with with what
I am what I deem is is my path or my
relationships or whatever I just say no
I mean I literally I am I am a definite
no person right time is a big issue for
me and we have a limited amount of it
and so saying no to talking to people is
right
I have the same in my head that says
that people that work with me are more
important than people that don't and so
I the fact that you and I are talking
right now my team will tell you that you
must really love Tim well I appreciate
you making the time because I would I
say no to everyone this is this is the
only one I've done and I just say no to
everybody categorically no I mean the
reason it's because when we woke up this
morning talking to that individual was
not on my game plan so at the end of the
day if talking to that person if I have
a spare moment and it's a kindness I can
do love to do that love to do that but
given my life and how big it is
there aren't many there aren't many of
those moments you know cuz I look up and
I go hold I have a spare a minute I need
to go hug my wife again I mean that's
the way I think about it I need I need
to go have my dog more right I need to
go do whatever that is within my my list
or at least within my focused categories
of the things that matter most to me so
I'm I'm a very much an oh man I just say
it over and over and over and over and
over again do you have any preferred or
default language that you that you'd
like to use or that you tend to use how
do you convey that to people and let's
let's assume it's not you know Joe Blow
from muckety-muck incorporated who is
just a random inbound because I'm
imagining you have filters for that type
of thing and even if you didn't you
would just ignore it but let's say an
old friend you've kind of drifted away
from manages to something I got a hold
of you and invites you to be on the
such-and-such board of some type and
you're like ah you know and you listen
to the you're a it's down your list B
you don't really want to do it doesn't
feel good what do you what do you say
well I'm fairly direct about it but III
believe in the love tough love
sandwich approach right so you know I
say hey Tim you typically this is in a
text or an email right because I don't I
don't allow people to talk to me get to
me via a phone or standing in front of
me because that that then becomes
awkward and now I have to deal with it
on their time schedule instead of mine
which throws my schedule off throws my
focus off or throat right so my standard
line is you know hey Tim this is me
typing it something and he says hey Tim
I really appreciate you thinking about
me to be honest with you I would love to
say yes but the problem is and I have
several scripts up for this problem is
if I say yes to you I have to say yes to
other people and because I don't have
time to say yes to everybody I have to
say no to everybody and I I'm so sorry
but I just can't do this
good luck I mean or or here so have you
tried to in Ferris I'll definitely you
know there's some if there's someone
else but that's kind of a standard line
for me my line is you were looking for a
script and that's the the underlying
script would be I can't say yes to
everybody so I'm gonna have to say no
yeah yeah cuz I get those requests I get
them every day they just fly at me same
with you I mean yes I don't we did it
absolutely I'm asking partially because
I want to borrow it's totally true by
the way is and that is I plan my time
months even years in advance now
understand I can always erase so I'm not
I'm not I'm not I'm not a rigid person
at all about that but might one of my
standard scripts is I'm so sorry I can't
do that I plan my time
you know years a year in advance years
in advance and unfortunately I'm on book
then oh yeah Ramon the guy that when
they recognized me as the second person
ever recognized from my high school I
didn't go to the awards when they when
they it when when I graduated from
college I just drove out of town I
didn't go to the graduation when they
named me the most that what was the the
most influential person of the year two
years ago I didn't go to the convention
to get my award when they when when
Austin recognized me as the entrepreneur
of the year I didn't go to the ceremony
so I have to buzz these are great how
what is and is the line I'm sorry I I
have planned years and months out in
advance do you remember specifically
what you conveyed to these folks are had
your assistants convey on which one any
of them
oh that's that that's exactly right did
that notes that that's the line and it's
so sorry he his schedule conflicts with
your date so he will not be able to
attend now we then offer up somebody
else that they want to go so for
entrepreneur of the year one of my
partner's went and it was so funny
because that I think that was the same
year that John Mackey of Whole Foods was
recognized he and I were Co recognized
and after so she got up and she spoke
about me right it's really hard for you
know if you win an award to go in and
say I'm awesome I'm great I'm through
thick I'm all these things that would
look stupid right right but if you sent
a proxy what's he stands up and says I
want to tell you about my dear friend
Gary Keller he's the most amazing guy
I've ever met I want to tell you a story
that exemplifies just a wonderful guy he
is right so so I've heard this more than
once where they'll come off the stage
and the person whoever they were with
goes I'm gonna get a proxy next time it
was awesome one of the most genius
workarounds I think I've heard in a very
very long time just put that down as one
of your time hacks me I will well that's
it that's how you do it oh my god it
works really well me that it works
genius so genius well I know we only
have just a handful of minutes left and
then I want to let you get back to
hugging your wife and wrestling with
your dog and doing all the other things
that you know that have to do today that
on a business level I'd like to ask a
question that I that I ask pretty often
and that is the Billboard question so if
you could put a quote a message a
question anything on a billboard
metaphorically speaking to get a message
of some type out to billions of people
let's say something non-commercial what
what might you put on the Billboard
think big aim high think big
aim high why is thinking big important
to you it's a theme that runs through a
lot of your writing Minh Buffett said it
really well when he said that the the
habits of our life are like change that
are too loose to be noticed until
they're too tight to break and when you
think about our life being built upon
habits you realize that most people
accrue habits instead of form good ones
and so when you think when you think big
and you aim high and you start running
towards that you have to develop big
habits scalable habits in order to
implement that plan so if you didn't say
think big and aim high what would you
say think small
would you think think low would you say
think average well if you didn't say
think big what what are the other
choices and most people by default
because they don't they don't think big
they don't aim high they end up
developing very average or below average
habits they in a developed right there
you're thinking leads to action action
over time becomes a habit so if I'm
thinking small then I'm forming small
habits and here's the problem when
Warren Buffett said now my and now now
I'm a person of small habits and all of
a sudden I look up
I go wow I really I really do want more
out of out of my life and then you have
to go break these habits and that's
really hard to do whether their eating
habits or exercising habits or you name
it that work habits or relationship
habits it doesn't really matter that you
know at the end of the day the if you
have a choice think big if you have a
choice aim high and then ask yourself
what do I need to do to do that and what
are the habits or what's the one habit I
need to develop such that by doing
everything else ishere necessary and go
get that habit but if you don't think
big what's your choice right yeah I mean
it's kind of the joke I tell the kids I
said something of this way so you fall
in love with someone and you want to ask
them to marry you and you go will you
marry me I
I've dreamed of our life together and
it's gonna be average we're going to
live an average life and live in an
average home drive an average car eat
average food take average vacations read
average books go to average movies we'll
have average friends will have average
parties and if we have kids we'll have
average kids we'll teach them you know
the virtues of being average right let's
get married it's gonna be awesome
[Laughter]
not personally and you but what you and
I both know is that if you don't choose
your life if you don't choose the
direction of your life you'll you'll go
in any direction you'll end up in places
that you didn't want to be at because
you didn't choose where you wanted to be
so think big aim high I put that on the
Billboard and and I want to also note
that you made a very deliberate decision
to look at and change your habits long
ago when when you noticed that you're on
this linear incremental path that maybe
was in some ways just kind of reacting
to whatever was in front of you or
whatever was expected to be the next
step
you you were able to redirect that
crucial handful of degrees that over the
long term is not a few feet it's not
a hundred feet it's you know thousands
of miles in terms of the difference
between where you could have ended up
and where you did end up right so it's
it's a very inspiring story you know one
of the things that I ultimately
developed was that the habit of being
able to develop a habit because in the
end at that singular skill becomes like
your superpower right the ability to
just call it the habit hack if you went
along but it's the ability to form a
habit and it's hard it's not easy it's
really hard I'm 62 years old it takes
time to develop the ability to say I
want that and ice now see the singular
habit that will get me there I'm now
going to develop that habit
aside from deciding on the habit as you
just mentioned have you found anything
in particular to help you to develop or
stick with you have it other people go
right your support system it's the
phrase that I used earlier and that is
your your environment has to support
your goal so your environment has to
support your habit too so you literally
if you want to form a new habit you're
gonna have to have your environment
support that you're gonna have to have
the people around you cheering for you
and supporting you to do that right I
had a Mary had an aunt who passed away a
few years ago this is wonderful
wonderful woman and but she was the size
of I don't know how to say it
she was massive and she's massive and in
her husband by the way was Jack Sprat
and in getting to know that family when
I came down to whose that is
who's that oh the skinny guy so Jack
Sprat knew know that right the yeah this
is there's a skinny skinny skinny skinny
man
and his thing was you know dear you can
go pursue anything you want around
health as long as the kids and I have
three square meals
and ready for us and they have to be
different meals and again she she she
she cooked she cooked for them and she
couldn't help herself she had to taste
it and she had to eat it and given her
body type and the way she was for him it
didn't affect him for her it completely
blew her up it was you know once you
realize that you go my gosh your
environment has to support your goal
that so to me that that that the habit
hack is go find somebody or a group of
people that will support you and then
build that support mechanism right make
sure that your spouse or significant
other or best friend or whoever make
sure that they're there in alignment
right tell them what your goal is don't
hide it I want to do this and I need
your help give me permission I give you
permission to to help support me to do
that this is the secret guide advice
yeah it's so critical yeah don't don't
rely on being the best captain and rough
seas that you manufacture yourself
that's exactly right
set your conditions I've just just just
perhaps two or three questions left one
I have to ask because I don't know the
answer why why do this interview I know
you're busy guy and you just mentioned
you do very little media so why why do
the podcast you know because I really
like and respect you to be honest with
you and you do a lot of good you know
when your first book came out I'll be
honest with you I looked through the
title and went that guy's full of it and
I read the book and then went oh my gosh
this is a significant book this is not a
trivial book he has a cool title but to
be honest with you what you wrote
everyone should read and I firmly
believe that and so to be honest with
you I'm just here to honor you it's an
honor that you would ask it's an honor
that you would ask me but more
importantly just the ability for you and
I just to talk for a couple hours is a
thrill for me and I just want to be
supportive I really appreciate that and
I I want to give give you I want to give
us
time for me to disappoint so hopefully
we'll feel this grab a cup of coffee or
break some bread back you know back in
Austin and this has been really fun I
really appreciate it and and valuable I
took tons of notes I have four pieces of
paper in front with notes scribbled all
over them then I'm gonna clean up
afterwards good notes and is there
anything else you'd like to say or
suggest mention websites social anything
like that of course I'll link to all of
that in the show notes so people will
have that on the website and via email
either way but is there any anything
else you'd like to say before we wrap up
you know I
if you mentioned sending people to some
places so I just started Jay and I
started our new podcast called think
like a CEO and so yeah telling people to
come and check us out and see if that's
a cool place to go learn would be
awesome perfect we'll send some we'll
send some some traffic so we will put
think like a CEO the link to the podcast
and we will put links to the books and
certainly the company and many other
resources in the show notes so everybody
listening those will be available as
always at tim dot block forward slash
podcast and gary thank you so much for
for taylor what i'm tim it was a blast
my friend thank you and to everybody out
there with earphones in or otherwise
thank you for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun for the weekend
and 500 Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
comm that's four hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by ring
this season can be a whirlwind of
deliveries visitors in holiday travel so
it's the best time of the year to
upgrade your doorbell and keep an eye on
home no matter where the holidays take
you I'm traveling a ton and this is key
for me ring helps you stay connected to
your home from anywhere so if there's a
package delivery or surprise visitor
you're getting alert and be able to see
hear and speak to them all from your
phone you're on the go the season
whether it's across town across the
country you can check in anytime for
some much-needed holiday peace of mind I
personally used ring for years now it
catches and of course all the regular
stuff like the movies and so on but it's
also saved my ass a few times catching
weirdos and weird things ring is key to
my peace of mind
and as a listener of the Tim Ferriss
show that's you you have a special
holiday offer on a ring welcome kit
available right now with ring video
doorbell - and chime Pro the ring
welcome kit has everything you need to
keep an eye on home no matter what this
holiday season brings with ring you're
always home just go to ring com forward
slash Tim that's ring com forward slash
Tim check it out traditional terms may
apply and this offer is for us residents
only that is ring com4 slash temp
this episode is brought to you by ship
station
if you've ever sold anything online or
if you sell anything online then you
know what a pain in the ass the shipping
process is it's time-consuming expensive
you're always copying and pasting orders
from different sites trying to figure
out the best carrier so on and so forth
it's such a hassle and in previous life
I shipped tens of thousands of units
overseas domestically overnight ground
every possible carrier it drove me
bonkers ship station was created to make
your life easier I wish I had had it
when I was in the biz so to speak it has
the most five-star reviews of any
shipping software four point nine out of
five for Magento users four point eight
out of five for Shopify users four point
five out of five for the comics users it
goes on and on whether you're selling on
eBay Amazon Shopify or more than 100
other popular selling channels
shipstation lets you access all of your
orders from one simple dashboard ship
station works with all of the major
shipping carriers locally and globally
including FedEx UPS and the major local
couriers like USPS ship station will
recommend the best carrier for your
needs so that you know that you're
always getting the best deal that even
offer discounts on shipping costs that
are available to state you as a
one-person shop that would normally be
thought of as reserved for large fortune
500 companies so there are a lot of
benefits no other shipping platform
makes shipping faster easier and more
affordable and right now Tim Ferriss you
listeners get to try ship station free
for sixty days when you use promo code
Tim risk free you can start your free
trial without even entering your credit
card info just visit ship station com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in
tim t IM that shipstation comm enter
promo code Tim check it out shipstation
comm promo code
you